Oi. Oi. Oi.
بالحرب سرا ان كنت لا تستطيع ان
تحارب في العلن. بريطانيا تتدخل
عسكريا في اوكرانيا نعم لقد
تدخلت واعترفت. وامريكا تضغط على
زلانسكي لاستشارتها في كل خطوة
والا وعرض اوكراني للسلام مع
روسيا وموسكو ترفض وايطاليا حدد
موعد نهاية المساعدات العسكرية
الغربية اهو ضجر غربي امستسلام.
والولايات المتحدة تظهر بصاروخ
مرعب يثير تساؤلات الصين وروسيا
واشتباكات عسكرية جديدة في
الحدود الهندية الصينية بينما
تتسكع قاذفات الصين النووية
بالقرب من تايوان. وتركيا تواصل
عملياتها العسكرية والجيش
الامريكي يتدخل يدوس على خطوط
بوتين الحمراء بارسال هذه الهدية
للجيش الاوكراني. ورقة الموت
الروسي. الجنود يتساقطون والبلاد
تدمر والظلام يسود اجواء
اوكرانيا. حسنا هنا لن يستمر
الدعم الامريكي الى الابد وحان
وقت المصارعة. وها هو الرئيس
الامريكي بايدن يضغط على زلنسكي
وبعد طالت الحرب ولم تتضح بعد
طريقة انهائها ليصل الامر الى
درجة طلب مشاركة الخطط العسكرية
الاوكرانية في الطاولة الامريكية
مع البنتاجون قبل تنفيذها وذلك
بحسب صحيفة بوليتكو. لكن المصادر
تضيف ايضا ان واشنطن وضعت شرط
مشاركة اوكرانيا اهداف ضرباتها
قبل تنفيذها لتزويدها بالسلاح.
فلما كل هذا الضغط الامريكي هذه
الخطوة الامريكية بعد ان اعترفت
روسيا واوكرانيا ان الوضع صعب في
ساحة المعركة في شرق اوكرانيا
وزعمت كل منهما ان نجح في صد
هجمات اخرى هنا مجزرة استنزاف
تشكو منها مفاصل الاقتصاد
الاوروبي. لينطلق مؤتمر دولي في
باريس بمشاركة سبع واربعين دولة
لحشد المساعدات لاوكرانيا
وبنيتها التحتية. الرئيس الفرنسي
ماكرون مصرحا دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي قدمت الكثير من
المساعدات الطارئة لاوكرانيا
وتخطط لتقديم مساعدات عاجلة ايضا
لقطاع الطاقة الاوكراني. مضيفا
ان تدمير روسيا للبنية التحتية
الاوكرانية يهدف الى اخضاع
الاوكرانيين. من جهة اخرى قال
ماكرون ان هناك محادثات تجري حول
الاتفاق لنقل الثقيلة من محطة
للطاقة النووية ليرد الكرملين
سريعا. انه لا وجود لاسلحة ثقيلة
في المحطة النووية. هناك تعهد
قادة الدول السبع الصناعية
الكبرى بتزويد اوكرانيا بانظمة
وقدرات للدفاع الجوي. واتفقوا
على انشاء منصة لتنسيق المساعدات
المالية لاوكرانيا. لينتهز
زلينسكي الفرصة ويدعو مجموعة
السبع الى حكومته بالحصول على
ملياري متر مكعب اضافي من الغاز
الطبيعي هذا الشتاء ودعم بلاده
باسلحة بعيدة المدى. ياتي ذلك
بينما وافق الاتحاد الاوروبي على
تخصيص ملياري يورو لدفع تكاليف
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا. ولا
زلنا في حرب المساعدات لكن هنا
مساعدات امريكية خطيرة يمكن ان
تندلع بسببها المرعبة بين الروس
والامريكان. اذ تضع واشنطن
اللمسات الاخيرة على خطة ارسال
منظومة الدفاع الصاروخي باتريوت
الى اوكرانيا بحسب شبكة سي ان
ان. لكن ارسال هذه المنظومة
يتطلب توقيع وزير الدفاع لويد
اوستن قبل ان تصل الى الموافقة
الاخيرة من الرئيس بايدن. وكل
هذه الموافقات لارسال لكييف
والتي من شأنها ان ترفع من حدة
بين موسكو والغرب وتعقد مجريات
الازمة عسكريا وسياسيا. لكن الرد
الروسي كان سابقا بان هذه
المنظومات ستكون اهدافا مشروعة
للقوات الروسية هنا المنبه
الايطالي. نعم. ايطاليا حددت
توقيتا مفاجئا لوقف الاسلحة التي
يدعم بها الغرب اوكرانيا حيث
اعلن وزير الدفاع الايطالي ان
شحن الاسلحة الى اوكرانيا سينتهي
بمجرد بدء محادثات سلام. حديث
روما عن السلام جاء بعد ان قدم
مطالبه ايضا من اجل السلام
وايقاف الحرب ليطالب روسيا بسحب
قواتها بشكل كامل من اوكرانيا
وعدم تقديم اي تنازلات وضمان امن
ووحدة اراضي اوكرانيا وتعهد في
حال موافقة بوتين على هذه
المطالب بالتحدث الى الغرب
لدراسة توفير ضمانات لروسيا. فهل
لا زال امر اوكرانيا بيدها بعد
هذا التصريح ليرد الكرملين فورا.
وعلى لسان متحدثه بيسكوف اذا لم
تقبل اوكرانيا بالامر الواقع فان
التقدم للسلام غير ممكن. وروسيا
ترفض مقترح للسلام وهذا امر غير
وارد. وفي لحظة صمت بريطانيا
تعترف للجميع. الجيش البريطاني
يعلن عن عمليات سرية في اوكرانيا
وذلك عبر قوات الكوماندوز
البحرية. حيث تم ارسال ثلاثمائة
وخمسين من الافراد لمرافقة
الدبلوماسيين من السفارة
البريطانية في كييف بداية العام
قبل شهر من حرب الروس على
اوكرانيا ليستمر تواجدهم بداخل
اوكرانيا حتى شهر ابريل الماضي
بداخل السفارة البريطانية وذلك
حسب صحيفة التايمز البريطانية.
لا يكفون عن استفزاز بوتين لتعزز
وزارة الدفاع البريطانية
باعلانها عن انتهائها من تدريب
تسعة عشر الف جندي اوكراني.
واضافت ان تسعة الاف منهم عادوا
بالفعل الى بلادهم ومعهم مائة
وخمسة وتسعون الف عدة ما بين
اسعافات اولية وحماية ومقاومة
شتاء. فماذا انت فاعل يا بوتين
بعد كل هذا? من فنون الحرب ان
تخضع عدوك دون قتال. نقصد هنا
حرب الغذاء الخارجية الروسية
تقول ان صفقة الحبوب تحتاج الى
تعديل لضمان وصول الامدادات
الغذائية الى الدول الاكثر فقرا
مضيفة ان اسطنبول تعتبر مكانا
مناسبا للمحادثات مع الولايات
المتحدة. فما كل هذه الثقة
باحفاد عثمان. الحرب الكلامية
النارية لا تنتهي لتبدأ شرارتها
الاولى من الطاولات الامريكية
حيث بدأت امريكا منافسة روسيا
والصين على القارة الافريقية
والهدف ثرواتها ليصرح جيك
سوليفان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي الرئيس بايدن سيرحب
خلال القمة الامريكية الافريقية
بانضمام الاتحاد الافريقي الى
مجموعة العشرين عضوا دائما.
واضاف ان ستلتزم بتقديم خمسة
وخمسين مليار دولار لافريقيا فهي
على هذا السخاء الامريكي.
الامريكان لا يتوقفون. والمنافسة
ليست بجمع الحلفاء فقط بل كشفت
الولايات المتحدة عن اختبار
ناجحا لصاروخ فرط صوتي يفوق سرعة
الصوت بخمس مرات والذي تم
اختباره واطلاقه من قاذفة في
جديدة من مسلسل التسلح العالمي
لامتلاك اسلحة ارتصوتية. الصين
تثير جنون الامريكان. اصحاب
العيون الضيقة لديهم خطة بديلة
لكل حروبهم العسكرية والسياسية
والاقتصادية فهم لن يتركوا
السيطرة للامريكان. نعم الصين
تخطط لضخ استثمارات بنحو مائة
وثلاثة واربعين دولار في صناعة
الرقائق الالكترونية في خطوة
لتحقيق الاكتفاء الذاتي من حزمة
اشباه الموصلات ولمواجهة تحركات
امريكية تستهدف التقدم
الالكتروني الصيني وذلك بعد
الضغط الامريكي لعدم وصول
الرقائق للصين. ميزانية بكين
ضاهت ميزانية واشنطن لما يسمى
باشباه الموصلات. فهي ميزانية
كافية يا ترى وبعد الحروب
الافتراضية ننتقل الى الحروب
الحدودية. حيث اندلعت الاشتباكات
العسكرية بين القوات الصينية
ونظيرتها الهندية في الحدود
الدولية ليتبادل الصينيون
والهنود الاتهامات بشأن مسؤولية
الاشتباكات حيث اصيب عدد من جنود
القوتين. غير ان البلدين اكدا
عودة الاوضاع الى طبيعتها وانهما
يتواصلان عبر القنوات
الدبلوماسية عسكري. ومن صراخ
الجنود الى صراخ صافرات الانذار
التايوانية. نعم لقد حركت الصين
قاذفاتها النووية بالقرب من
تايوان. لتصرح وزارة الدفاع
التايوانية في بيان لها ان احدى
وعشرين طائرة دخلت مناطقها خلال
الساعات الاربع والعشرين الاخيرة
والتي تشمل ثماني عشرة قاذفة من
طراز ذات القدرات النووية بحسب
ونادرا ما ترسل الصين اكثر من
خمس قاذفات في يوم واحد لكن
الطلعات ازدادت بشكل كبير خلال
الاسابيع الاخيرة فهل حان الوقت
لتندلع حرب الاندومي؟ لقد مللنا
من التهديدات يا هؤلاء. تركيا في
حيرة من امرها. تركيا لن تتوقف
قبل ان تصل لهدفها المنشود. فها
هو التركي يتجدد على مواقع قوات
سوريا الديموقراطية شمالي سوريا
ليخرج نائب وزير الخارجية الروسي
ميخائيل بوجدانوف قائلا موسكو
تواصل اقناع انقرة بعدم شن عملية
عسكرية برية في سوريا. ليأتي
الخبر الامريكي الذي حير الاتراك
هذه المرة باعلان البنتاجون
استئناف الدوريات المشتركة مع
قوات سوريا الديموقراطية كامل
وذلك بعد تعليقها بسبب الضربات
التركية ليتحدث المراقبون ان شبح
العملية العسكرية البرية التركية
في الشمال السوري قد انتهى. فما
الذي ستختاره تركيا يا ترى الحرب
او عدمها فيما شبكة الاستخبارات
الامريكية تعلن عن صيد اسرائيلي
في قلب تركيا. حيث اعلنت السلطات
عن اعتقال اربعة واربعين شخصا
الانتماء الى شبكة تجسس تعمل
لصالح الموساد الاسرائيلي في
اسطنبول هذه هي ثمار التطبيع
وحان قطافها. امريكا تضغط على
اوكرانيا فهل يكون ذلك من اجل
السلام ام من اجل اطالة امد
الحرب?